مشهد الالغام لم يفارق مدينه خرسون الحياه
لا تزال بعيده عن طبيعتها رغم انسحاب
القوه الروسيه منها ومناطق مجاوره
لازاله مخلفه الروس من خطر لدخولها من
جديد حيث ترك الروس
القاتله الى جانب مواصله قصف المدينه
بالمدفعيه من مواقع عبر نهر
عن عدم استقرار امدادات الكهرباء رغم وصول
المياه الى جزء كبير منها
لكنها يقول المسؤولون في المدينه حين نحو
80% من سكان خرسن البالغ عددهم حوالي 320
2007 بعد احتلالها من الروس فيما يقتل
المدينه التي بدات وكانها مدينه اشباح نحو
70 الف اوكراني يلتزمون المنازل خوفا من
موت محتمل كما حصل مع بعض الموزيليا
الالغام العسكريين في طرقات المدينه
محليون بطريقه اخرى حاله الطرق السيئه
سادهما القاتله وزراء الغام كثيره في حفر
مغطاه بالتراب
تحرس القوه الاوكرانيه على تامين بعض
الطرق وتنبيه الماره من وجود الغام فيما
تنتقل فرق اخرى بحذر من منزل الى اخر
لضمان تامده وسط اجواء من الشكل حول وجود
اشخاص قد يكونون تعاونوا مع الروس او ما
زالوا يتعاونون معهم